we've spent four months investigating
bombings and travelling inside edlin
we've tracked down first responders
traced some of the children injured
interviewed eyewitnesses gathered
previously unseen footage and gained
access to an underground network of
spotters intercepting fighter pilot
chatter we have a mass of information
which lays out the case for war crimes
about the attack the Russians insist
never happened
[Music]
[Applause]
July 22nd was the bloodiest day ever
remembered in marathon human and this
was only the start the second shelling
is about to hit in an area known as the
skini district we piece together a
comprehensive timeline of what happened
that day and where and it completely
challenges the claims by Russia and the
Syrian regime that this never happened
[Music]
one of the first on the scene was
American teacher Rania Kaiser
[Music]
now back home in Washington MS Kaiser
wants those responsible held to account
I am holding the United States
responsible for these atrocities because
of their apathy you know staying silent
to crimes like this is exactly like
becoming a partner of it she documented
the chaos of the day body parts of the
Dead were strewn everywhere I'm walking
and the first thing that I see is a
piece of leg and by the time I got to
the heart of the hole I looked at the
left and there was a store that I know
the people that work in and they sell
falafel i buy falafel from them every
morning and there was a kid there who
was about maybe 16 or 17 years old he
was still alive his intestines were
completely out of his stomach
and he was saying Ya Allah Ya Allah she
ran with a group of others fearing
another attack taking shelter and plane
we pray to God of course we all wear
primarily to God this is what they
always do this is their tactic they
share all the first time and they wait a
few minutes until people on the ground
gather to rescue each other and then
they shell the second time and that's
when the impact that big impact truly
happens it's it's a conniving evil
method you know you wanna it's not like
you want to kill a specific group you
want to kill everybody even the rescuers
even as the volunteer medics headed off
with some of the wounded another bomb
landed near the hospital maarat
al-nouman is the second-largest city in
Italy province a sprawling residential
neighbourhood home to tens of thousands
of people the first bomb landed at just
after half past eight in the morning in
the middle of a market area about eight
minutes later the second landed in the
same spot a double tap aimed at killing
those rescuing the injured from the
initial attack it's also an area
populated by schools across the city a
little over a kilometer away and barely
11 minutes later a third lands near a
mosque and a hospital and at nine
o'clock the fourth is dropped adjacent
to a cultural center but the most killed
that day were around the twin bombings
in the market area it was packed with
shoppers and homes thirty men six women
and eight children died including a
white helmets rescuer in the crater they
used to be a three-story apartment six
families lived here all perished or at
least that's what they thought one of
the first activists and filmmakers on
site the destruction was terrifying in
every sense I used to draw into film
that
it was huge it was clearly a public
market with lots of shops and all of
them smashed to pieces they were
searching the rubble for about six hours
before they heard a girls voice
it was between only seven years old and
she was kneeling unconscious of the time
they pulled her free the rescuers then
turned to her little brother
three-year-old Alfred
at first they weren't even sure he was
alive but dazed and with a bad eye
injury he was also pulled out somehow
the two of them had survived they didn't
know then that the rest of the family
both parents and all siblings were dead
the white helmets volunteer who rescued
them both told us they worked for more
than 12 hours straight that day trying
to save lives the civilian casualties
were high
we've spent four months talking to the
man who pulled the children free piecing
together what happened and we've
traveled to it live several times to
track down other witnesses and survivors
to the marital Newman bombings
the craters are still there and the
mental scars are as raw as ever at the
beginning it was very difficult at night
we all have nightmares sometimes see
myself trapped in the rubble or I dream
about aircraft targeting but the
bombings just didn't according to the
Russian Defense Ministry he sure does
Cooper sure would I want to emphasize
that Russian aviation was not used in
this area on July 22nd and did not fly
there you dumped nearly power at the
time they produced maps showing the
market intact all fake news according to
the Russians in fact they were focusing
on an area 300 metres away from the
actual market which was hit we put our
investigation findings to the Russians
several times but haven't yet received a
response we spoke to the network of
underground monitors intercepting Syrian
regime and Russian fighter pilot radio
frequencies we're keeping them secret
for their own safety they've built up a
log of fighter jet departure times and
their log matches the timing of the
bombs dropped over Maarat al-numan that
day their timings are also corroborated
by eyewitnesses that the russians denied
responsibility to this massacre we're
positive they did this and it is a
bombing hospitals is also a war crime
many of the casualties in the marathon
human airstrikes would ordinarily have
come to this hospital but hospitals are
incredibly dangerous places in it Lib
now and there are a few still operating
this one set in the middle of an olive
grove with no other buildings around and
it's GPS coordinates had been supplied
to the United Nations of which Russia is
a member we searched through the debris
to find as many documents as we could
and it's the list of the patients
and this is blood analysis the paperwork
shows there were patients being treated
inside the hospital building when it was
hit these are all war crimes say the
medics working in Italy
public health centers with the United
Nations so they know everywhere and they
perform many many of them the two
siblings pulled out alive from the
rubble of their home in meratol Newman
spent weeks in hospital we followed
their progress since the bombings but
told was much more seriously hurt and
needed several operations and there are
more planned after suffering severe
internal injuries both children were
brought to Turkey for further treatment
and to be looked after by elderly
relatives who'd already fled Syria Ahmed
and his sister have a long recovery
ahead but they are getting better able
even to play with toys now like other
children they both still need a lot of
medical help but they are safe and alive
but the bombing of civilian targets like
the children's home and hospitals is a
systematic way of pushing the population
out of an area and appears to be a
tactic which is being carried out with
impunity
Alex Crawford Sky News ed Lib